[موسيقى]
انضمامنا للنيتروجى لاننا بحاجه للحمايه
التي يوفرها البند الخامس وقت
لن تخترق حدودنا ليس هناك تهديد حقيقي
لكننا نود ان يبقى الحال كذلك في المستقبل
اي انه لو اصبحت روسيا تهددنا فان دول
النيترو ستهبل مساعدتنا في حال تعرضنا
لهجوم ولهذا السبب طلبنا الانضمام لنيته
وما كان لهذا الامر ان يكون مطروح في
فنلندا او السويد لو لم تقم روسيا
بالاعتداء على اوكرانيا فهذا الانضمام
بسبب الحرب والعدوان الروسي على دوله
المجاوره لها
[موسيقى]
لابد من انهاء الحرب على الجميع
الحرب لانها تؤثر على كثير من الدول
بدرجات متفاوته والشعب الاوكراني الذي
يعيش الحرب الان يخسروا ارواح الابرياء
يوميا نهيك عن دول اوروبا الاخرى التي
تتاثر بسبب الطاقه ودول العالم التي تتاثر
بسبب الغذاء فنحن نواجه قضايا كبيره
متعلقه بالامن الغذائي لان روسيا تمنع
تصدير القمح الاوكراني الى خارج البلاد
الحرب تؤثر على كثير من الدول باشكال
متعدده وعلينا ان نعمل لضمان وقف الحرب
[موسيقى]
اثرت القسمه على فلندا بارتفاع اسعار
الطاقه نحن دوله مجاوره لروسيا ولذلك كنا
نعيد انفسنا على مدى فتره طويله لذلك نحن
لا نعتمد على الوقود الاحفوري الروسي كما
هو حال دول اوروبيه عديده كنا نحضر انفسنا
مسبقا لكن ارتفاع اسعار الطاقه اثر على
مجتمعنا ومواطنين وشركاتنا واعمالنا وهذا
يتطلب منا ان نتاكد من اننا نستثمر في
مصادر الطاقه المتجدده واناناس سنتمكن من
تحمل الشتاء وليس الشتاء القادمه فقط
[موسيقى]